Hello! Welcome to Michael's Business Top Tips.
My name is Michael Jones and today, I'm looking at goal setting.
Now, every day in our general life and especially in business,...
...we are setting goals, targets or objectives we need to accomplish.
However often we don't think, "How can we set the most effective goals?"
Now, there's been a lot of research done into goal setting.
And the research has shown that using clear, effective goal setting techniques...
...improves your business efficiency, and your likelihood of achieving your goals.
Today, I'd like to recommend SMART goal setting technique.
SMART means: Specific, Measurable, Attainable, Realistic, and Timely.
When you're setting goals in the future,...
...for business or study, or losing weight, or whatever,...
...try to remember that SMART technique:...
...Specific, Measurable, Attainable, Realistic, and Timely.
Try this yourself.
Now, set three business goals that are SMART...
...and set three personal goals that are SMART.
For example, a personal goal could be,...
..."I will learn ten new English words from AERA English this month."
That would be a SMART goal.
Okay, I hope you enjoyed this month's Top Tip.
Next month, I'll be back with another Business Top Tip.
See you then, goodbye!